we've been reporting on the Blockbuster
changes in cable news and Blockbuster is
a word here affecting two of the most
high profile personalities on TV in a
surprise move Fox News parted ways with
Tucker Carlson yesterday he was a
Network's most popular Prime Time host
and one of the most influential
conservative media voices on the air
shortly after that long time CNN hosts
Don Lemon says he was fired by the Cable
News Network Lenin says that he was
stunned when his agent broke the news to
him We're joined Now by Ben smithy's
editor-in-chief of semaphore he's also
author of the upcoming book I love this
title traffic genius rivalry and
delusion in the billion dollar race to
go viral can't wait to read that Ben
Smith but for now let's talk about the
big changes in the landscape we'll start
with Tucker first because they said that
fox says that they had mutually agreed
to part ways that clearly does not seem
to be the case on Friday he was chomping
on Pizza saying I'll see you Monday and
then the the removal is effective
immediately also never a good sign no
goodbye no no goodbye so what exactly
happened here I don't think that anybody
has been given a reason about why he was
let go yeah I mean this was a mutual
agreement that seems just played out
over about 15 minutes yeah I mean it was
a rapid mutual agreement
um and there's been reporting you know
that he that he had been disrespectful
to his bosses and emails that he'd said
offensive things about women in emails
that have emerged in court all this
stuff was known for a long time and and
I think I was just texting with somebody
senior at News Corp people there don't
know what the sort of what the final
straw that maybe last Friday caused the
Murdoch family to um to push him out was
and they said that it came from the top
that Rupert Murdoch said he's got to go
you know I mean I think the company is
saying that the official leadership um
Lachlan Murdoch and Suzanne Scott made
the decision but I don't think a lot
happens there that Rupert Murdoch
doesn't approve and he's made a series
of quite dramatic decisions recently he
called off his engagement a few weeks
ago and he um and fox was set to merge
with News Corp and they called that off
recently too so what happens to the
vacuum on Fox News
also were you surprised because Tucker
was so powerful and said so many things
that he's let to go left to go unchecked
for many many years what happens now you
know I think I think Tucker was even
even in the context of fox he was pretty
unusual he was leading sort of a
conservative a right-wing populist
movement from inside Fox where he's out
there interviewing you know Victor Orban
the Hungarian prime minister this wasn't
standard issue Republican politics and I
think it likely goes back to something
more like you know loyal Republican
Talking Heads who are you know holding
to the party line who are attacking Joe
Biden but who aren't heading out into
the Fringe that way so where does Tucker
possibly go from here and do political
candidates follow him for interviews you
know I think political candidates are
actually me pretty relieved a lot of
Republicans lived in fear of what Tucker
Carlson was going to say about them and
also watched his show incredibly
carefully for what bill they could
introduce the next day to please him I
mean he was sort of he was really an
entity into his own right and and I
think I think and where he goes there's
nowhere like Fox for him there is you
know you suggest there's startups
there's the daily wire a conservative
startup you could imagine no but
nobody's I'm not sure anybody can afford
a you know reported 20 million dollar
Contracting it was Golden Goose there
why was he allowed to operate that way
Ben for so long because his numbers were
so so good it brought in money why you
know it's the Murdoch world is pretty
unusual they give people a lot of leeway
until they fire them it's not a tightly
run ship and fox in particular had
become a place where the the talent the
hosts just exercise enormous power and
the and the central leadership who
reported up to a family office you know
had a lot of trouble telling them what
to do let's turn to Don Lemon who said
he was blindsided stunned yeah he said
stuns he's the only one who was stunned
right uh what do you make of that
situation and how he described it in his
statement yeah I think I mean I think he
was I mean I think he probably shocked
but not totally surprised because he had
been you know he had had some
self-inflicted wounds but he was also
the face of the Trump era CNN that was
this kind of fighting anti-trump outlet
that that whose new owners had decided
basically it had gotten two partisan
we're trying to move it back and lemon
you know I think had been doing what his
bosses had asked him to do in the Trump
era which was be this you know fighting
anti-trump voice in the new era former
bosses his former bosses in the new era
Under New Management was trying to
become a cheerful moderate morning show
character
um was he struggling with that fit and
what was yeah and I think that was not
the most natural fit for him but but
also I think they they wanted to move on
they wanted to show that they were in a
new era of CNN and he was a sacrificial
well they certainly have been sending
that message were you surprised that
they responded to Don's statement where
he said they didn't nobody had the
decency to tell him and then they said
oh no what he said is inaccurate he was
given the opportunity to talk to
management and instead chose to go to
Twitter were you so surprised at CNN
management responded to that yeah I mean
these are both pretty bitter departures
I mean there's a you know you can you
can let people have a last show and say
goodbye to the audience and neither Fox
nor CNN yeah that'd be customary I would
think Ben Smith thank you thank you